[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: So at
the end of last time,
let me just restate the
theorem that we proved,
which was the
Weierstrass M-test, which
I'll state in briefer
form now as the following.
Suppose fj are a sequence of
functions from some subset
S of R, so that for all j, there
exists non-negative number M
sub j, such that
two things hold.
First off, these M sub j's
dominate the f sub j's.
f sub j of x is less
than or equal to M sub j.
And two, these M sub
j's are summable.
Then the conclusion is, the
sequence of partial sums.
So converges uniformly.
So there exists some
function f from S to R
so that the partial
sums converge uniformly.
So this is a sequence
of functions built up
by the fj's by just taking
the sum of the first j
equals 1 to n of them.
And so, for example, and I kind
of went through this last time.
So example, if fj of x equals
our old friend cosine of 160jx
over 4 to the j, then--
and let's say on R. So S is R.
And a couple of things.
fj of x for all x is less than
or equal to 4 to the minus j.
Because cosine of
whatever you put into
it is always bounded by 1.
And since this
converges, this implies
that this series, which I'm
writing in this way, which you
should think of as
a limit of functions
of the partial sums,
which are functions,
converges uniformly on R.
Not only that, this
function defined by--
I take x, I stick it into here--
is continuous.
Because last time, we proved
that the uniform limit
of continuous functions
is continuous.
This function here
is the uniform limit
of the partial sums, which
is just finitely many cosines
of things.
So that's continuous.
So this gives another
proof of one of the things
we did by hand when we spoke
about differentiability, namely
that this function that we
considered was continuous.
So let's go back to
power series, which
was our original motivation.
So I'm going to be
saying that a series--
so let me, again, make
this perfectly clear.
When I say, if you like,
make this a definition.
Or really, this is just a--
I was using this terminology
up there in that theorem
and when I was talking about
this example afterwards.
But when I say a
series involving
functions converges uniformly,
I mean the partial sums
converge uniformly.
So means there exist a
function f such that--
and all of these are from
S to R as well, such that--
just so that there's
no ambiguity.
So if I have a
sequence of functions,
f sub j, and I
form their series,
and I say that converges
uniformly, that
means there exists
some function f,
so that the sequence
of partial sums--
these are now functions--
converges uniformly
to the function f.
That's what power series are.
They're expressions
involving a free variable x.
And therefore, you
can think of them
as a series involving functions.
So let me just state the
following theorem about when
we have a uniform convergence.
So let's suppose we have
a power series with radius
of convergence rho,
which I will recall
is defined to be the limit
as j goes to infinity, aj
1 over j inverse.
If this limit is 0, we say
that the radius of convergence
is infinity.
So if this is a
finite number, this
is a meaningful expression.
If this is 0, then
this is shorthand
for saying the radius of
convergence is infinity.
So let's assume this is--
then, as long as I stay
strictly inside the radius
of convergence, I have
uniformed convergence.
This is the statement
of the theorem.
And for all R in 0 rho, this
power series, now thought
of as a series of functions of
x, converges uniformly on x0
minus R, x0 plus R.
So the picture is, we have some
radius of convergence, x0, x0
plus rho, x0 minus rho.
If we take any closed
interval, basically,
inside of that-- strictly
inside of that interval,
then we have uniform
convergence of the power series.
So we'll prove this using
the Weierstrass M-test.
So let R be in 0, rho.
And for all j--
and OK, so the
Weierstrass M-test
is for j equals starting
from 1 and going to infinity.
But you don't have to,
just like for series, we
don't have to start at 1.
It can start at 0.
So for all j union
0, what do we have?
What are we writing?
And for all x in
this interval where
we want to show
uniform convergence,
we have that this
function a sub j,
x minus x0 to the j
in absolute value.
What is this bounded by?
This is bounded by absolute
value of aj, and then j.
And because x is in this
interval, its distance to x0
is less than or equal
to R. So R to the j.
So this will be my Mj that I'll
use for the Weierstrass M-test.
Let me put that in parentheses,
because I may not use that Mj.
So these individual
functions, just polynomials,
are bounded by this
number for each j.
And now, I want to see if
the series of involving
these numbers converges.
So let me apply the root test.
We have this is equal to--
now, this R to the 1
over j just becomes R.
And it can just come
out of this limit.
And I pick up a to the 1 over j.
And this is equal
to 1 over rho by--
so this is equal to, if you
like, I can put R over rho,
as long as if rho is
less than infinity.
Meaning if the
radius of convergence
is less than infinity and 0.
And what do we notice?
Now, R is less than rho.
R is coming from the closed
interval 0 up to the rho,
not including rho.
So this number-- so this
is always less than 1.
But this number is
always less than 1
too, as long as R
is less than rho.
Which implies that
the series sum from j
equals 0 to infinity of
aj R to the j converges.
So now we have the
sequence of functions,
the polynomials that we used
to build up our power series,
each of them bounded by
these numbers, a sub j,
absolute value times R to the j.
And these numbers are summable.
The series converges.
So by the Weierstrass
M-test, this
implies that the
power series converges
uniformly on this interval.
So as long as we stay strictly
within inside the radius
of convergence, we have
uniform convergence
of the power series.
And therefore, using the
theorems that we proved before,
we can differentiate and
integrate term by term
the power series.
So which follows immediately
from this previous theorem
and then what we proved last
time, which I'll state now.
The power series with radius
of convergence rho positive.
So let me write it this way.
And the first is for all c
inside x0 minus R, x0 plus R,
the function given by the power
series, which I'm not going
to call this f or anything.
I'm just going to refer
the power series directly,
this is differentiable at c.
And to compute the
derivative, you
can just do it term
by term, meaning I
can take the derivative inside.
By dx of j equals 0
to infinity, a sub j,
evaluated at x equals c.
This is equal to simply
differentiating term by term.
And number two, for all a
less than be, well, with x0
minus rho less than a, less
than b, less than x0 plus rho--
so here I'm sticking to
strictly with inside the radius
of convergence.
There's the x0 plus
rho, x0 minus rho.
And so, now I'm going
to integrate over
some interval inside.
Then I can integrate
term by term.
The integral from
a to b, sum from j
equals 0 to infinity of a sub
j, x minus x0 jdx equals--
and I'll just write it
this way, sum from j
equals 0 to infinity of--
OK.
And in fact, let me
just to really emphasize
that we're interchanging
limits here,
let me instead write this
equivalently as sum from j
equals 0 to infinity of
sub j d by dx of a sub j,
x minus x0, j evaluated
at x equals c.
So for power series, I can
interchange the limits.
The limit being taking
a derivative in the sum,
I can interchange.
And then, I can also interchange
the integration and the sum
as long as I stay within
the radius of convergence.
And this statement
here is a point-wise.
So let's see why
one is the case.
Two follows immediately
from what we've proven,
and so, this previous
theorem and the theorem
we have about integration
and uniform convergence.
So what about one?
So first off, we know we
have uniform convergence
of the series strictly inside
of the radius of convergence.
So how about, we
need to check to see
if the formal derivative also
has radius of convergence
as well equal to rho.
So I claim that the radius of
convergence of the derivatives
which equals--
I can write it this way.
No.
So the derivative of this
guy is j times a sub j times
x minus x0 to the j minus 1.
So just shifting indices, this
is equal to times j plus 1,
times x minus x0 to the j.
So our claim is that
this power series here
has radius of convergence equal
to rho, the original radius
of convergence.
So rho is the radius
of convergence
of-- why did I come over here.
I still had a board left.
Sorry about that.
The original power series has
radius of convergence rho.
What we need to
show to prove part
one is that the
radius of convergence
of the derivatives of taking
the derivatives inside also
has radius of convergence rho.
Because then, this would imply
that this power series, which
is the derivative of
that one, converges
uniformly on the same set.
So then we have
uniform convergence
of the power series and uniform
convergence of the derivative
of the power series.
So by the theorem we
proved in the last lecture,
we would have that the
derivative of the power series
equals the power series
of the derivatives.
So I'm just going to
focus on this claim.
And this, again, just follows
from what we know about limits.
And so, we compute that
if we take the limit as j
goes to infinity of-- now,
these are the coefficients
for the new power series.
So aj plus 1, j plus 1
raised to the 1 over j,
this is equal to limit
j goes to infinity
of a sub j plus 1 now raised
to the 1 over j plus 1, j plus
1, 1 over j plus 1.
Now all raised j plus 1 over j.
Now, this was a special limit
that we looked at last time.
This, the limit as j goes to--
not last time, but
way back when we
were looking at
sequences-- the limit
as j goes to infinity
of this guy is 1.
So this in fact equals
limit as j goes to infinity,
this goes to 1, this goes to 1.
So you can actually say
this converges to 1 as well.
So this equals to
the j plus 1 over j.
Now, strictly speaking,
you would have to--
so this thing also converges
to-- what does it converge to?
This remember, is-- so
where do we have it?
Do we still have it up here?
So the radius-- well,
it's way over there.
So let me recall that the
radius of convergence rho,
let me put an
inverse here, this is
equal to the limit as let me put
a k goes to infinity, of a sub
k, 1 over k.
So this is the exponents
converging to 1.
This is converging
to rho inverse again.
So I get rho inverse to the 1.
So therefore, this is
supposed to be the radius--
1 over the radius of convergence
to the differentiated power
series, which implies the
differentiated power series.
j is 1 over this limit,
1 over that limit,
which we computed is
to be is 1 over rho,
which is the original
radius of convergence.
So all this to say is that
the radius of convergence
of the differentiated
power series, the formerly
differentiated power
series, is the same
as the radius of convergence
of the original power series.
And therefore, you have
uniform convergence
of the derivatives wherever
you have uniform convergence
of the original power series.
And therefore, by the
theorem we proved last time,
since both the derivatives and--
so since the power series and
the derivative of the power
series converges
uniformly on the same set,
the power series--
the infinite sum, so this guy
is actually differentiable.
And the derivative
of the power series
is the power series
of the derivatives.
But you can iterate this,
because I now have this power
series with radius
of convergence
equal to the radius of
convergence of the original.
And then, I can take
a derivative of that
and show that has the
same radius of convergence
as the original.
So let me just leave
this as a remark
and not state it as a theorem.
Iterating can prove that if
I want the k-th derivative
of the power series.
So on-- so let me say, all x
in here, the k-th derivative
of the power series is
equal the power series
of differentiating term-by-term.
So this holds for k
equals 1, 2, and so on.
And so in particular,
if I evaluate at x0,
this tells me that
k factorial, a sub k
is equal to the derivative
of this function, which
is what you get out when you
stick x into this power series.
And you can interpret this,
although we never called
them Taylor series, as a
statement that every power
series is the Taylor
series of a function.
At least in this setting
that we're looking at.
So we've answered
pretty definitively,
at least for the
scope of this class,
when we can
interchange limits, we
can do that as long as we
have uniform convergence
of the objects that
we're interested in,
be it the function, the
continuous functions,
or function and its derivative.
But there are more powerful
statements out there
that one can make, especially
when it comes to integration.
This is why essentially why a
different theory of integration
was created, or one reason why.
But hopefully, if I see
some of you in 18 102,
which is what I'm
teaching next semester,
we'll get into that
further when we
discuss Lebesgue integration.
That was thought of because
somehow Riemann integration is
not complete the same way that
the rational numbers are not
complete.
Riemann integration
is not complete,
Lebesgue integration is
complete in a certain sense.
I'm being very vague
here for a reason.
So I'm just giving you
where you can go with this.
Is what the next step is
at least improving when can
you interchange two limits
is really a topic that's
fundamental to the study of--
in the study of
Lebesgue integration.
And you have much
more powerful theorems
there than you do
here, which allows
you to prove interesting
results, and especially about
Fourier series.
In fact, if I had
more time, we would
apply, in fact,
some of the stuff
that we've done
here we could apply
to the study of Fourier series.
But maybe we'll
do that in 18 102.
So I want to now prove the last
theorem of the class, which
is also due to the godfather.
So when we had
these power series,
so these are defining
functions, very special types
of functions, what
are called analytic.
They are by definition
essentially the limit
of polynomials.
They're the limit of these
finite sums of a sub j's times
x minus x0 raised
to the j power.
That's a polynomial.
So for analytic
functions, which are
these functions equal
to power series,
they are the limits
of polynomials.
But that's a pretty
small class of functions,
analytic functions.
But Weierstrass proved this
very interesting result
that actually
something like this
is true for all
continuous functions.
So roughly speaking,
Weierstrass proved
that basically every continuous
function is in some sense
almost a polynomial.
Just as we solve for these
analytic functions, meaning
defined by power series,
they are very close to being,
at least within their radius
of convergence, a polynomial.
In fact, this is true for
all continuous functions,
that not necessarily
equal to a power series,
but every continuous function
is almost a polynomial.
And in what sense
do I mean that?
So this is Weierstrass's
approximation theorem,
which states the following.
If f is in continuous function
and on the unit interval,
say, you can make it a, b, just
by rescaling the variables.
But I'll just state it
for continuous functions
on the unit interval.
Then there exists a
sequence polynomials
p sub n of x, such
that p sub n converges
to f uniformly on 0, 1.
And so, in this sense,
every continuous function
is well approximated
by polynomials.
So every continuous function
is close to being a polynomial.
So I need to first
prove a couple
of things that will be needed.
So first off, I'm only
going to look at only a--
so let me make some remarks
before we go to the proof.
So we're putting the
proof on hold now.
So let me just make a remark.
I don't necessarily need
to prove this statement
for every f, just for certain f.
And then for every f will
follow from this special class.
So we only need to consider--
we'll only consider the case,
f of 0 equals 0, and f of 1
equals 0.
So f is 0 at the end points.
Why we're doing
this is so that we
can extend f to a continuous
function outside of the unit
interval by just
setting it equal to 0.
And so, let's suppose we've
proven this special case
and we look at the general case.
Then if I take any
continuous function now,
what do we know that there
exists sequence of polynomials,
p sub n, such that
these polynomials,
p sub n converge uniformly
to a small modification
of f that results in--
so this function
here, if I look at it,
it's a continuous
function on 0, 1,
because I'm just modifying it
by constants and then times x.
And then at f of 1, I get f
of 1 minus f of 0 minus f of 1
minus f of 0.
So I get 0.
And at 0, I get f of 0 minus 0.
f of 0 is 0.
Minus 0 times something,
I don't care, equals 0.
So there exist polynomials
converging to this function
now.
If we've been able to prove the
case just for f of 0 equals 0
and f of 1 equals 0.
So uniformly, and therefore,
the polynomials given by p
sub n of x plus now x times
f of 1 minus f of 0 plus--
so this is still, if
this was a polynomial,
so is adding this to it.
That's still a polynomial,
converges to f tilde
of x uniformly.
And this, again, this
is still a polynomial.
So the whole point
of this remark
is that we only need to consider
the case f of 0 equals 0
and f of 1 equals 0.
And we're going to do
that just so that we
can extend f to a continuous
function outside the interval.
Now, the way we're going to
build these polynomials that
converge to f is by what's
called an approximation
to the identity.
Really, I guess you could
think of it as an approximation
to the delta function.
And I'll explain that
in just a minute.
So for all n natural
number defined c sub n,
this will be the integral
from minus 1 to 1 of 1
minus x squared raised
to the n, dx, 1 over.
And then, q sub n
of x, this is going
to be equal to c sub
n times 1 minus x
squared raised to the n.
Then a few simple consequences
are, so first off, this
is the integral of a function
which is non-negative,
but it's positive at plenty of
places between minus 1 and 1.
And you proved in the
homework that this
means that the integral
has to be positive.
Then the first is, for all N
natural number, for all x in 0,
1.
So the first two of these
observations are very clear.
qn of x is greater
than-- so minus 1 to 1.
qn of x is bigger
than or equal to 0.
So it's just c sub n, which
is a positive number times 1
minus x squared. x squared,
so x is between minus 1 and 1.
And therefore, 1 minus x
squared is always non-negative.
Two is, this is
also pretty clear.
The integral from minus 1 to 1
of q sub n of x, dx equals 1.
Now, why is this clear?
Because this is equal
to the integral of 1
minus x squared raised to the
n, times c to the n, or c sub n.
But c sub n is the
inverse of that integral.
So we should just pick up 1.
Now, the third and less trivial
thing, which is important,
is that for all delta in 0,
1, this function q sub n,
I mean, this is just a
polynomial, converges to 0
uniformly on the set
delta is less than-- so
x such that delta is bigger than
or equal to the absolute value
of x.
No, delta is less than or equal
to the absolute value of x
is less than or equal to 1.
So in other words, here's minus
1, 1, 0, delta, minus delta.
If I look in these
regions, so, if you
like, in the union of
those two intervals, then
q sub n, this polynomial,
is converging to 0
uniformly as n goes to infinity
on the union of these two
intervals.
So what is the picture
of what's going on?
What do these q
sub n's look like?
So here's minus 1.
Here's 1.
So the first one it looks
like some constant times 1
minus x squared.
So there's the first one.
And then, as n keeps
getting bigger and bigger,
this is 0 at higher and
higher order at 1 and minus 1,
and getting pretty
small near here.
And in fact, according to three,
if I take any interval around 0
and look outside of it,
as n goes to infinity,
q sub n in is going
to 0 uniformly.
So what it should look like
is, maybe the next one,
it's like that.
And then further
still, like that.
So that if I look inside
over here, or over here,
q sub n is going to 0 uniformly.
So what you should think
of is that the q sub
n's as n goes to infinity is
something like a direct delta
function, which is not
exactly a function.
So again, so let me
re-emphasize that--
and this is in quotes--
you should think of q sub n acts
like delta function centered
at x equals 0.
So that's in quotes,
because that is meaningless.
But some of you
who've taken physics
know what the properties
are of a delta function.
And the integral is 1, it's
somehow 0 everywhere away
except for the origin.
And it's infinite there.
But somehow, it's integral 1.
So these q sub n's
will show a form,
an approximation to the
identity in a certain sense.
But let me-- let's prove these.
Let's prove the only
non-trivial one, which is three.
Number one and two are clear
based on how they're defined.
So let's first estimate
how big is this.
So this constant c
sub n, we don't really
know what it is explicitly.
But let's compute at
least a rough size of it.
So and then, we'll use this
to prove the third part.
So we have for all N
and natural number,
the following inequality in xn
minus 1, 1, 1 minus x squared
raised to the n, this
is greater than or equal
to 1 minus nx squared.
Now this, if it's not--
so it shouldn't be like--
hit you in the face
clear why this is true.
But one way you can
prove it is that if you
look at the function g of x
equals 1 minus x squared n.
So first off, this
inequality is even in x.
It doesn't matter if x
is negative or positive.
So let's look at this function.
On 0, 1, then what's the point?
I look at g of 0, this is 0.
And if I compute
g prime of x, this
is equal to n times
2x times what?
Times 1 minus 1 minus x
squared to the n minus 1.
And this is always less
than or equal to 1,
this thing in parentheses.
So this thing is always bigger
than or equal to 0 on 0, 1.
So on 0, 1, this
function is increasing.
And its value at 0's 0.
So we get that, which is
exactly what we wanted to prove.
So now we compute
the size of c sub n.
So to do that, let me
look at 1 over c sub n.
If I want an upper
bound on c sub n,
I need to prove a lower
bound on 1 over c sub n.
So let's take 1 over c sub n
and find a lower bound for it.
This is the integral
from minus 1 to 1.
So 1 minus x squared
raised to the n, dx.
Now, I can't remember if I made
this a homework problem or not.
But for even functions
integrating over an interval
even with respect to the origin.
This is just twice--
I mean, I'm sure you
remember this from calculus.
It's not hard to
prove with what we
know of the change
of variables formula
and so on, that this is equal to
twice times the integral from 0
to 1 of 1 minus x
squared raised at the n.
Now, this is bigger
than or equal to 2 times
if I integrate to
a certain point.
This certain point
is chosen so that I
get a result in the end
that's pretty, essentially.
Now, this is where
I replace this
by the smaller thing,
which is easy to integrate.
So this is greater
than or equal to 2,
integral 0 1 over root
n, 1 minus nx squared dx.
And I leave it to you to
verify that with this choice
of the endpoint what I get is
4 over 3 root n, 1 over root n.
And therefore, so and this
is bigger than 1 over root n.
So I started with
1 over c sub n.
And I showed that it was
bigger than 1 over root n.
And therefore, c sub n
is less than 1 over--
is c sub n is less than
the square root of n.
Now, we'll use this to
compute what we want.
In fact, I mean, we
really just needed
to show that c sub n is bounded
by some polynomial in n.
But this will suffice.
So we now want to show--
so let delta be positive.
We now want to show that Q7 q
sub n converges uniformly to 0
on that set where the
absolute value of x
is less than or equal to 1 is
bigger than or equal to delta.
Now, we note that the following
sequence converges to 0,
that square root of n
times 1 minus delta squared
raised to the n.
So we should also
put deltas in 0, 1.
So this sequence here converges
to 0 as n goes to infinity.
Now intuitively, why is this?
This is because this is
some number less than 1
raised to the n-th power.
Exponential always beats just
a polynomial or a power of n.
If you want to see
exactly why this is,
we could compute
the limit as n goes
to infinity of this sequence
raised to 1 over n power.
Then this is equal
to the limit as n
goes to infinity of n
to the 1 over n 1/2,
1 minus delta squared.
And this converges to 1.
We proved that.
And so, this equals 1
minus delta squared,
which is less than 1.
And we have this theorem
from our section on sequences
that says, if this
limit is less than 1,
then the thing here
converges to 0.
Or you could interpret
this as saying
that the series with this as
the individual terms converges.
And therefore, the individual
terms have to converge to 0.
So which implies limit as n
goes to infinity equals 0.
So now we have this.
And once we have this,
we'll have what we want.
So we want to prove uniform
convergence on that set.
So let epsilon be positive.
Then since this
sequence converges to 0,
there exists in M
a natural number,
so that for all n bigger than
or equal to M, square root of n
times 1 minus delta
squared raised to the n
is less than epsilon.
And for all n bigger
than or equal to M,
for all x so that delta
is between less than 1,
we get that q sub n,
so it's non-negative
minus 0 in absolute value.
That's just q sub n
of x raised to the n.
This is less than or equal
to the square root of n.
That's for this guy.
1 minus x squared,
this is getting smaller
as I get closer to 1.
So its biggest at delta.
And how we chose M is,
this is less than epsilon.
So now, we're ready for the
proof of the Weierstrass
approximation theorem.
So suppose f is continuous
function on 0, 1.
f of 0 equals 0,
f of 1 equals 0.
So this polynomial here
is very concentrated at 0.
So well first off, suppose f--
and it's continuous here.
So you can check
that if it's 0 there,
and I extend it to
be 0 outside of 0, 1,
this is still a
continuous function.
I'm just defining it
this way because I
want to write certain
symbols in a little bit
without specifying exactly where
the bounds of the integration
are.
So we extend f by
0 outside of 0, 1.
And this function f
is continuous function
on the real number line.
So we define-- now
we're going to define
this polynomial, sequence
of polynomials, p sub n.
This is going to be equal
to the integral from 0 to 1
f of t times q sub
n of t minus x, dt.
And just to remind you, this
is equal to the integral
from 0 to 1, of f
of t times c sub
n, 1 minus x minus t
squared raised to the n, dt.
So this is just c sub
n times this thing.
If you expand everything
out, is just a--
using the binomial theorem,
this is equal to j equals--
I'm just going to
put a sum here,
meaning a finite sum, of
some numbers a sub j, n times
x to the j, times t to the--
well, just some finite numbers
a jk, times x the j, t to the k.
All I'm saying is,
if you expand this
out using the
binomial theorem, you
get this theorem, this
polynomial and x sub j,
t sub k.
And then, this is getting
integrated against f of t dt.
And so, this is in
fact a polynomial.
And I'll give you--
so let's write this
out and be precise,
just so that you're convinced
that it's a polynomial.
This is equal to the integral
from 0 to 1 of f of t times
c sub n.
Now we use the binomial theorem.
This is equal to j 0
to n, and choose j.
And then, minus
x minus t squared
raised to the n minus j.
Or I could put j, 2j.
And then, det. I'm
not sure if this
is even helping or anything.
But just so that you see this
is actually a polynomial.
f of t, c sub n, sum
from j equals 0 to n.
And now, sum from k equals
0 to 2j, n choose j minus 1
to the j.
Now, 2j choose k minus t to
the k times x to the j minus k.
And then, dt.
So I have all this
junk integrated dt,
and then this is x
to the 2j minus k.
So that just pops out.
So this is a polynomial.
I mean, this is a polynomial.
But then, when it
integrates against f of t,
this x to the 2j minus k
comes out of the integral.
And I get that times just all--
this becomes a sum of terms
with x to the 2j minus
k outside this integral,
times f of t, times
integrated against
minus 2 to the k.
I think I said more
than I needed to there,
but so the point is p sub
n of x is a polynomial.
Now, we can write this
slightly differently.
So piece sub n of x, this is
equal to just as it was before.
Now this, we change
variables and is equal to--
so we do a u substitution now,
where u is equal to x minus t.
And then I'm going
to change the dt.
So what I did here was
a change of variables.
By setting u is
equal to x minus t.
Or I guess, if you'd
like, t minus x.
And then, I just
recalled-- and then
I just called ut then again.
So I'm eventually looking
at these polynomials only
in the interval 0, 1.
So this is what it looks like.
But now, this f
of x plus t, for t
between minus x
and 1 minus x, it's
actually 0 outside of that.
So I can extend the
integration to minus 1 and 1.
Again, with the understanding
that I've extended
f to be 0 outside of 0, 1.
So since fy equals 0--
or let me write it this way.
Since f of x plus t equals 0 for
t not n minus x and 1 minus x.
So that was a lot of
explaining for some stuff.
But here, let me
get to the point.
What is p sub n really?
So why should you expect
this to converge to f?
So this is a little discussion.
So I said that--
and this is for those
who understood my comment
about delta functions.
In q sub n is very concentrated
at 0, at t equals 0.
So this, you should think
of as being approximately
like a delta function at t.
If you don't know what delta
function is or never heard
of it, then forget the
rest of this remark.
But and then I'll say something.
So q sub n kind of looks
like a delta function.
And therefore, minus 1
of x plus t qn of t dt
should look more and more like
f of x plus t delta of t dt.
And what we know about
direct delta functions is
that when you integrate
them against a function,
you just pick up the function
evaluated at 0, which is--
OK.
So that's kind of
why you expect it.
I mean, if you look back at
this picture of what the qn's
are looking like, they are
concentrating more and more
at 0.
So all of the contribution
to this integral
here, which defines these
polynomials, is happening at t
equals 0.
At t equals 0, I
just pick up f of x.
So that's why you
should kind of expect
these polynomials to converge
back to the function.
So I think I can
finish on this board.
So this is a picture you should
have seared in your mind.
This is what the q
sub n's look like,
that they're concentrating
all of their mass right
at the origin.
And therefore, I should just
pick up f at the point x.
since this is concentrating
at the origin, t equals 0,
I should just pick
up f of x plus t at t
equals 0, which is f of x.
And why f of x plus t, not some
constant times f of x plus t,
that's because the
integral of q sub n's is 1.
So now, let's prove that the
pn's converge to f uniformly.
So let epsilon be positive.
Since f is a continuous
function on a closed and bounded
interval, we know that
it's uniformly continuous.
And therefore, there exists
delta positive such that--
how am I writing this here?
Such that if-- let's write
it this way-- for all y,
so that z minus y
less than delta,
we get that f of z
minus f of y is--
actually, we don't need--
OK.
So I mean, we don't
need so much of about f.
But we'll go with this anyways.
We really just know--
OK, never mind.
I'll stop.
So we know that f is
uniformly continuous
so there exists a delta,
so that I have this.
Yeah, so less than
epsilon over 2.
So z and y are within
delta to each other.
Then f of z and f of y, no
matter what z and y are,
are within epsilon
over 2 of each other.
Now, since f is continuous, it
has a maximum on this interval.
Well, I should say, since
f is a continuous function,
it has both a max and
a min on this interval.
And m there exist some
number c such that f of x
is bounded by c
for all x in 0, 1.
So now I have this delta coming
from the uniform continuity
of f.
I have this c
coming from the fact
that it's bounded
on this interval.
And now, I'm going to choose my
M for the uniform convergence
of the polynomials
just depending
on these pieces of input.
Then as we showed, since
square root of n 1 minus delta
squared and converges
to 0, this implies
there exists an M
natural number so
that for all n bigger
than or equal to M,
I get that square root of n
1 minus delta squared raised
to the n is less
than epsilon over 8c.
I claim this M works.
That for all n bigger than or
equal to M, for all x in 0, 1,
pn minus f is less than epsilon.
And for all n bigger than or
equal to M, for all x in 0,
1, if we look at p sub
n of x minus f of x,
we're going to use
that this thing is
an approximation
to the identity,
meaning it's essentially
that it satisfies those three
properties that I
wrote a minute ago.
So this is equal to
integral from minus 1 to 1
of f of x plus t times
qn of t dt minus f of x.
What's the integral from
minus 1 to 1 of qn sub t?
That's equal to 1.
So f of x is at times--
so this is-- all of
analysis is writing
1 or 0 in a certain way.
Not all, but-- so I can write
this as f of x plus t now
minus f of x times qn of t, dt.
Again, because the integral
of q sub n of t equals 1.
So again, if you just expand
this out, this is f of x.
I'm integrating
with respect to t.
So I just pick up
what I had before.
Now, by the triangle
inequality for integrals,
this is less than or equal to
the integral for minus 1 to 1
of f of x plus t minus f of x
times the absolute value of q
sub n of t.
But since q sub n of
t is not negative,
that's just q sub n of t.
And now, I'm going to split
this integral up into two parts.
This is equal to
a part where t is
less than or equal
to-- so should
minus delta, delta
f of x plus t,
minus f of x, q sub n of t dt.
And then plus the other
part, which I can write as--
so it's a union of the two
intervals now away from delta
out to 1.
So it's the sum of the integral
over these two intervals, which
I'm going to write
as the integral over
delta less than or equal to
t is less than or equal to 1.
And times qn of t.
Now, t is between
minus delta and delta.
And therefore, x plus t
minus x in absolute value
is less than delta.
So in this integral
here, I want to note
that if t is in this interval
here, x plus t minus x equals
t is less than
delta in this here.
So since this guy minus
this guy is less than delta
in absolute value, I can use
this uniform continuity part
to say that this is less than
epsilon over 2qn of t dt.
Plus now the absolute value
of this guy is less than--
by the triangle inequality-- is
less than or equal to the sum
of the absolute values, which
is less than or equal to c--
2c.
So 1, and then 2c.
Because that's bounded by
c, that's bounded by c.
So the absolute value
of the difference
is less than or equal to the sum
of the absolute values, which
is bounded by each of
those bounded by c.
Now, this is less than
epsilon over 2 integral
from, if I just integrate the
whole thing, from minus 1 to 1,
that just gives me 1.
Plus 2c times qn of t.
On this interval is, again, so
I shouldn't put a delta there.
2c, c sub n, 1 minus delta
squared raised to the n, dt.
And so there's no t here.
So this is equal
to epsilon over 2,
because this integral
is 1 plus this--
c sub n, remember, is less
than the square root of n times
1 minus delta squared
and times the integral
over this region dt,
which I can make bigger
by going from minus 1 to 1.
It gives me 2.
And this is equal
to epsilon over
2 plus 4c square root of
n, 1 minus delta squared n.
And this is less than epsilon
over 2, plus epsilon over 2,
equals epsilon.
I think I have one
minute to spare.
So this was quite an experience
teaching to an empty room.
I hope you did get
something out of this class.
Unfortunately, I wasn't
able to meet a lot of you.
And that's one of the best
parts about teaching and being
able to see you grasp in real
time what I'm talking about.
So hopefully this
nightmare will end soon,
and we'll get to see
each other in the future.